[Music]
without any further ado one more time a
big round of applause for tonight's
speaker all my life I never wanted to be
anything else from before I could read I
knew that's what I wanted to do and
because I'm a generalist in several
sciences and the arts I come across a
lot of really strange things and you
will find out about these in a little
bit this is the painting forest floor
that's back there that I did in 2007
it's all species that are new to Western
science I say Western science because
there's a begonia here that's called
begonia Lizotte Lizotte means delicious
in malay so it wasn't new to the people
there it's new to the Linnaean system
and new to Western science you know
that's a fairly complicated painting
it's not one you try as your first one
ever it's been said that I I make
paintings of the natural world through a
500-year viewfinder I have studied the
Dutch still-life masters extensively but
how did I get to this point that's kind
of what I'm gonna try to show you
tonight I came here from there 3404
Hawthorne Avenue in Richmond Virginia
there were 54 kids on my block when I
first moved there each house was on an
acre lot
and they backyards all connected so we
were free but we also had to learn
responsibility we had to all know when
to call an adult and when not to and
there's you know there's a lot of
pecking order in that so we've learned a
lot and had to become very fluent in
responsibility quickly my father was a
naturalist my mother was an artist and
my great-uncle had a 500 acre plantation
on the James rivers where we were free
to do anything we could get away with
including diving from the top of the
silo into the grain which is really
crazy but it it's where my love of the
natural world began was in that farm I
remember what I was wearing when I saw
this picture on the left of one of
Michelangelo's slaves I could not read
yet it was one of my mother's art books
and if you if you look at think about
the rock and not the sculpture you think
that's just a rock and I remember having
that thought and thinking there's some
something there's a transformation
happening there to me that to me is
really powerful and I want to do that
that's what I want to do the other image
on the right is Galileo's first drawings
when he looked through a telescope at
the moon
his entire worldview his mind said his
time would tell him to disbelieve his
eyes but he did believe his eyes and it
was very powerful for me too in defining
how I wanted to try to make work because
your mind can tell you one thing but
your eyes tell you a different thing and
I wanted to respond to my eyes I did a
lot more of my growing up here at this
place this is where I went to work for
two weeks and stayed for four and a half
years at the offices of coevolution
quarterly even though I did a random set
of jobs everything from making lunch to
debugging hourly code when we went from
spindle cards to a mainframe computer
for our subscription list but I got to
be a community of the ideas of that
place and it had a profound impact on my
life and on my thinking at the same at
that time I was working I was living in
South of Market which was a real ghost
town back then and working in the arts I
helped start open studios and I was
making work out of trash basically
because it didn't have a whole lot of
money also I lived in San Francisco
because I was afraid to move to New York
when I was only 19 and so I thought well
I'll make a idiot of myself in San
Francisco first so this is an example of
the kind of work I was making it was
trying to marry two and three dimensions
making padded skull
sure sculpted paintings these were all
little buildings I saw from a moving
train and they were mysterious to me so
I was trying to create some recreate
some of that feeling of mystery that's a
chicken coop with the first taxidermy
bird I did it's a rooster that somebody
didn't want anymore
and then a small cinema that when two
people sat inside it a little pixelated
film showed the cinema building itself
other side of the room had a library
that was filled with handmade books for
one person if that's Karen Finley by the
way it's either just as an aside one of
the books that I'm we were friends at
the time one of the books I made was
made out of latex and it was had had
intaglio drawings of body textures so
pubic hair nipples whatever and it was a
rubber book it was made for rubbing
which I gave to Stuart brand when I left
San Francisco for New York I believe
it's at Stanford now they're trying to
fix it or recreate it or some so knowing
Stuart I got to meet Jon Brockman and I
moved to New York in 1980 the evening
and left the evening that Reagan was
elected and I thought oh my god I'm
headed for Armageddon it's the end of
the world but little did we know back
then and when I moved to Stanford to New
York there was a somebody had painted a
bull's-eye in the middle of one of the
big intersections like Canal and
Broadway and that was that was a landing
spot for Skylab premiere when that was
going to come crashing through and there
was a REM did a song that was a little
later but it was you know it's the end
of the world and we know it but I feel
fine that was my feeling when I got to
New York like it's all going to hell in
a handbasket but I'm here so I kept
trying to Mary to in three dimensions
against the grain entirely with the art
world but this was another building in
an exhibit that had no musical
instruments I had the leaves on that
table that had thousands of them the
floor was miked there was a book that
you had to open up to get
you had to actually walk the book open
like this to read it and this was a
torture chamber sorry and all you could
see was the classical vices and virtues
made out of various things that was it
real art ways but at the same time and
forgive me for the poor quality of this
but somebody just sent me this iPhone
photo of a piece I made that I'd
completely forgotten about my first
husband had a his family had a house up
at Moosehead Lake in Maine so I would go
from the what my father called the
bowels of New York up to this incredible
natural place so the balance was really
helpful
that's a loon carved out of wood which
was a nod to what sculptures and all you
know that whole bird carving thing and
some three-dimensional water all through
the 80s I made these sculpted paintings
and sculpted painted sculptures these
were this was a set of paintings that
were hung from the ceiling so the front
in the back were two sides of one issue
so this was feast and famine I had mind
and body love and peace I mean a war in
peace and love and hate so they're you
know they really are built out from the
canvas though it was part of an exhibit
at new lankton arts Reni Pritikin was
has always been really good to me and
the whole exhibit was about duality and
the faults of thinking dualistic alee I
also made a bunch of Malcolm Forbes but
one Russian easter egg so that he would
have the largest collection so I built a
whole bunch of him so he wouldn't but
they were of course made out of garbage
you know this was sort of the last group
of things I made in New York this was a
cabinet that was supposed to prevent all
the objects were made with the intent
this is going to prevent nuclear
Armageddon I was really interested in
anthropology I liked reading about how
native cultures local cultures imbue
objects with power and how they come to
have power so you know it's working we
haven't had one yet you know with the
canopic jars that are back there a few
other objects are in there they were all
built I was
like really be intense and focus really
hard like this is gonna help make
something not happen also our dining
room table chairs for those of you
who've been to our house we're part of
this exhibit but it never went anywhere
I couldn't find anybody in New York and
wanted to show my work so I said I'm not
making work I made a public announcement
of not making artwork ever again so some
friends quickly made me try to help them
finish their thesis films at NYU so I
art directed films for a few years
including for the Coppola Tsai help do
the early there the kids the next
generation of Coppola to help them make
their first movies but and it brought me
back to San Francisco which was great
from New York in 89 I hadn't actually
really quit I was still making this
series of about 20 person miniatures
that Illustrated a short story on the
back actually was a short story and they
were illustrations they were designed to
work as a kind of a tarot deck in a
weird way one of the things that blew me
away about working in the film industry
is the amount of waste there is we'd go
through ten pallets of luan 500 gallons
of paint for what you know for a silly
silly movie that had no there are some
great films I believe in film but the
waste is really astonishing so it was
one of the things that made me want to
stop making sculpture and start to make
something that had a much smaller
environmental footprint you can take
these little bits of rare earth pigments
and and make this incredibly
transformative thing happen and I was
really interested they also they're much
easier to store and you don't have to
haul crap all the time and about this
time I saw a great still life exhibit by
the Dutch masters of the periods late
1600s and I was blown away that these
things looked as fresh now as they did
then and I was got really interested in
that idea this was a little side piece I
had going on 20 or some paintings I've
never shown anybody they were all
endangered plants and animals and I had
a medi
turn or a handprint so to me they were
represented sore the hand of man which
took away their a chance of surviving
and the hand of man that was also trying
to keep it just to survive allow it to
survive and that sort of led indirectly
into this whole series I did in about
the mid-90s I guess that was called
nature in the margins so it was my local
environment where something was
surviving in this little pocket that was
undisturbed you know it was just a
Golden Gate transit bus going by but you
know things just will survive if they
have enough room and it also gave me
this incredible opportunity to go
through lots and lots of trying out of
materials of mediums of pigments and
that's how I find about mummy Brown so
people used to actually grind up mummy
brains to make a color that's roughly
that color maybe a little more brown in
my monitor it's a little more brown it
wasn't a very good pigment it got very
expensive so people started grinding up
any old mummy a cat or bones or whatever
and it was also called k-put mortem
which means dead head weird
we've now have much better colors that
are much more permanent but you know
Indian yellow was made out of cow dung
that marigold petals were their only
food coach Anil is the squished up scale
bugs and growing cactus and we still use
that as a number one red dye and
lipsticks and whatnot and there's lots
of those so what I was interested in was
the difference between a fugitive color
that will not last and a pigment that is
pure enough and stable enough that will
last for an unknown amount of time so I
was at some of at least one of those
early long now meetings trying to build
models as ideas were flowing around
about how a library might look and so I
was already thinking and kind of a
parallel track about permanence about
how to make something that might be
worth a that might last and be some sort
of statement there might be worth
blasting having
and and about 98 I got a mailer from the
Sierra Club it was the hundred most
endangered animals in the United States
and this sir aha moment you know that
you have I said like I'm gonna make a
Dutch still life fading which you know
if I heard myself I would have thought
wait a minute are you crazy but I just
decided to try it and this was the
result at the time I didn't have any
real credentials in science I went to
five universities I think and these were
the in date this was the list of the
endangered things that I could get
access to so it's it's a very odd
collection of things fortunately I now
have enough credential that I can go to
almost any Museum and use their
collection which is fantastic I always
have mistakes like Navajo rugs most of
the time they're not on purpose but
sometimes they are and this was used by
the all species project another time
that I collaborated with Stuart and Ryan
and long now precursors along now that's
the San Francisco garter they're in the
lower-left fortunate I did most of this
work in public libraries and Cal Academy
library fortunately I met John McCosker
around this time and he introduced me to
a bunch of scientists I think he'd just
given up and said I was going to keep
asking questions so they might as well
let me in probably saved him time each
of the paintings that I started in this
Taxes series grew out of the first one I
mean out of the previous one so one of
the things that causes endangerment is
something else moving in and just doing
it better and out competing the previous
marker in that niche so these are all
quote-unquote invasive species in the
United States now there's a few trust
territories thrown in for the hell of it
but this was really fun because instead
of having to work from pictures and
books I could actually just go out and
chop the stuff down and paint from life
so that was really fun I've never gotten
to do it again the composition here is
sort of a figure eight
the compositions are built very
carefully to keep make sure that your
eye is always drawn from one thing to
the next and you don't even realize it
when I do it right I wish I could
remember that one's close to a hundred
one of the reasons that I don't like
saying invasive is because there's a cow
bird egg right here the speckled egg is
a cow bird egg they called him cow birds
because they followed buffalo herds
originally so dropping an egg in a nest
made sense because they were always on
the move but once the herd stopped going
they followed him because they would
stir up the cows with the Bison would
stir up bugs birds you know you get it
but once the Bison weren't doing that
anymore the cowbirds just started laying
eggs all over the place and it's caused
a lot of trouble for Warblers and other
things that have similar egg size this
was actually have two things that were
sort of in here about DNA one is there's
a square yard of fescue underneath
everything that's supposed to be a
square yard of grass almost all seed
grass is some fescue is very maybe 2-3
at the most species that are ever sold
as grass seed lawn products are one of
the main reasons that they're few
lightning bugs left anywhere in the
country and also the strawberries in
corn were sort of a I was already
thinking about genetic modification of
food and monocultures where we don't
have lots of different species we only
have one or two sorry
the species are always life size unless
I make a mistake largemouth bass have
been introduced all over the world by
fishermen in every freshwater in the
country for sure by fishermen so in
nineteen where was it oh yeah about the
edge 1999-2000 my husband and I moved to
London so I got to work on Internet in
international museums and so I chose an
international theme one of the other
things that drives endangerment is trade
black market trade in animal products
and animals
second only to guns by some estimates
that it's a real big money generator
and the more endangered something gets
the more valuable is which drives the
desire to get it and sell it on the
market it was great fun to be able to
work at cue and work with traffic
international I was kind of a nobody but
I just sort of wiggled my way in like a
brash American because I really wanted
to get the research done one of the
things that one of the reasons that I
built this painting about black market
trade is that I also wanted to talk
about great market trade something we
don't talk about as much
it's an uncovered trade so you know
matsutakes can be found in the North
Pacific Northwest an individual
matsutake sells now for about seventy
five dollars in Tokyo that's a big
market driver and this thing on the
right of right is American ginseng does
not govern it is in mostly in the
Appalachians Great Smokies and the
Appalachians nothing wrong with it it's
a cash crop for poor Appalachian people
but it also happens to grow in an area
that has the highest endemism of
salamanders in the world and we don't
know whether it has an impact hopefully
somebody's written about it since I did
the painting that long ago kind of
growing out of this whole thing I
started working toward things that had
gone extinct so I began it took me about
I did about four years of research on
extinction because I had to kind of find
the pieces and follow the stories bit by
bit what kept happening is I would say
well this went to the brink and then was
found or it went to the brink and
somebody carefully brought it back the
Mauritius Kestrel up there at the top
was saved by one man over the course of
two years the whole species sorry I lost
my track each painting begins as a
database by the way not as a drawing and
I was already working on building this
gone database when this sort of said but
this is a great one you know these
things have come back so I've read about
this Magno
in the secret life of plants by Richard
Attenborough and BBC and it was about a
Magnolia that was found in Japan and a
2,000 year old jar of rice some seeds
were there they planted them lo and
behold it's a new species and I thought
well the how perfect I'll use that it's
kind of my coat hanger you know how I
arranged the painting and I'll find out
about it later so I just was busy
working on the painting and emailing
people and all the magnolia people I
spoke to who said there'd know their
seeds are notoriously short-lived I
finally ended up writing BBC
Attenborough the [ __ ] the University of
the Japanese researchers couldn't find
the researchers so I wrote Gillian
prance who used to be the secretary of
cue and his response was is he I can't
help you with this one I think it's a
hoax the whole thing was a hoax but I'd
already done so much as I've worked that
I decided to leave it in there as to
represent our desire for nature to be
resilient I've taken thousands of photos
obviously this just happened to be one
of my favorite ones it was one songbird
Audubon named and really liked Verma
Vora Bachman I and that's actually a
painting of my favorite photograph so
finally we get to gone so these things
are extinct everywhere at the full
species level with one extinction
because I always I mean one exception
because I always have one it's one of
the earliest extinctions we know of is
the Blue Book it's I couldn't fit it in
obviously so I just used the horns took
photos of them in Paris they went
extinct when guns came into Africa as
soon as there were rifles the Blue Book
blew buck went it was heavy meaty slow
its leather was really strong and it was
gone this is our revive and restore
banners from his painting there's one
pheasant feather here it lives at the
British Museum it's been DNA tested it's
different from our existing
Argos pheasant and that feather is all
that's left
that one feather
it was it was called the double band of
darkest pheasant this is a little wren
that was flightless that lived on Steven
island off the north coast of of New
Zealand anyway a cat between the time it
was sent off to be identified and the
time the news came back yes this is a
new species to Western science the
person who sent its cat ate every bloody
one of them so but this is what I do I
go and I look at the original thing
because they're textures you can't see
in a photograph they're things like it
looks gray because it's skin is grey not
because the under feathers are great the
things you can't figure out like that
without seeing it with your own eyes
this is some typical happens to be the
passenger pigeon which I thought was
appropriate typical field drawings for
me making color notes text your notes
details that you can't see unless you
have a really close-up photo I went to
Papua New Guinea and have a bunch of
these drawn from a bird expedition I was
on so when I start ok I go from a
database and the original description to
a rough drawing that's life-size so I
know if this is a black and white bird
it's gonna draw a lot of attention in
the in the painting so I'm gonna have to
be careful where I place it so that
might be my first one but I actually
want it turned around the other way or I
want it going like this or like that and
so sometimes I have 30 to 40 drawings of
the same animal and I do them on trace
because if I want to change this
position of the head I just plop in a
new head and I don't lose all that rest
that drawing time so then I put each one
of those together I have to have an idea
first of how I'm going to arrange them I
start with like the four or five big
things so they'll be balanced I need a
piece of blue tape that's top and then I
just build this sort of schematic and
instead of like drawing a whole thing
over every time I'll just do one little
part and retrace it so then I'll take
when I have a finished drawing I don't
thank you writing when I have
finished drawing that's the full scale
that I'm happy with I just draw it all
over again with a piece of carbon paper
underneath it and transfer it to the
canvas that's kind of joke it's it's
kind of like carbon paper and then my
husband said yeah this is just paint
right number after that yeah so I liked
it it made me laugh I like jokes so this
is just details from from gone the
passenger pigeon Carolina parakeet
laughing owl went extinct because it had
no fear of humans and no other predators
and they just got trashed you know that
each one has an incredible story about
why and how it went extinct this was an
ostrich egg that was carried around for
50 years by some Colonel Dottie some
Colonel Lawrence and Richard
meinertzhagen who's I'd love to tell you
that story but I don't I'm but the
Colonel Lawrence was Lawrence of Arabia
how did he carry an empty ostrich Aram
ostrich egg around for 40 years without
break-in it so and they were in the
Middle East
ostriches all over the Middle East I
included jars because wet collections in
Natural History Museum's
sometimes the what they're put in
maintains the DNA better than just a dry
specimen and at the top right is a
gastric brooding frog that's one of the
species that's been under consideration
correct so that's this is ivory-billed
woodpeckers I love them they're really
so cool that tail feather is it's like a
piece of wood that they actually rock
back and use it there's a little V at
the tip because they wear off the rest
of what the tail feather used to look
like just incredible Birds their bill is
actually a chisel I just learned that
woodpeckers actually do a lot of their
noise making as territory display not
digging and feeding anyway I would love
to see them brought back they're a my my
pet species they actually also have a
tendon
goes from the edge of the jaw wraps
around the back of the skull and anchors
up here it is a shock absorber for the
brain and there's a parallel one in some
woodpeckers that for tongue extension so
that was like seven years spent on just
bad news bad news it's also great I was
really depressed but at the same time
when I was doing research on all those I
would be talking to a bird guy or a herb
guy or whatever and he'd say yeah that's
all really cool but let me show you what
I just found and it's like they would
turn into a 12 year old kid all that
wonder would be alive again so I thought
well that's good what I'm gonna do next
I'm gonna do things that have just been
found so that's how Nova was born
originally I was gonna do a perfect cord
seven paintings but there was so much
wonderful new stuff that I just got
totally carried away so here we are back
at forest floor I wanted I call them out
door still lives because it's still a
shallow depth but and I lost myself
sorry oh I wanted this painting in
particular when there's so much detail
you kind of just want to go like up and
closer and closer and I wanted it to
fill your whole frame of reference so
that when you were in close you were
really surrounded by that world again
with all these paintings working out the
compositions really tricky this one also
has a nice Easter egg that nobody but me
and whoever owns it next will know these
are glow-in-the-dark mushrooms in real
life and in the painting what I didn't
tell you about this is work is that I
thought oh this is great these are new
species they're gonna be so easy to
research and in the end I had to email
almost every single describing scientist
to get their photos this was sort of the
second level in my imaginary rainforest
the understory filtered light all that
kind of stuff I tracked journals and
digests on the web for probably five
years to find trying to learn about all
these new discoveries and I built this
one on a plant that's a night blooming
ginger
called macrocarpa parada they kind of
loomed up out of the myth so they like
Harry Potter's operating and I met the
scientists who did it who founded in
Ecuador and borrowed Alecto types from
them and thought oh this is great oh and
I would never have known the texture of
the flowers if I hadn't borrowed it and
I got I thought he was in Ohio and he
ended up being in Switzerland and it
cost me four hundred dollars to get them
to see Odie but that's the way it goes
it was a big email project this little
dark monkey at the top which I can't I'm
sorry I can't dredge up the name at the
moment that baby was actually the size
of a thumb and it was bought brought to
mark Van ruse Malin in a tuna can and
ended up being a new species I had such
great emails with him he invited me to
the Amazon but between the time he
invited me and I got around to going he
was arrested for bio piracy which wasn't
true but he's now not in the Amazon
anymore this is a this is one of my
favorite paintings gone and canopy are
really my two favorites so this is kind
of the crown of the tree
the third story up if in but it's all
imaginary these things are from all over
the world they are at life-size but they
are totally imagined in an imaginary
place most of them are tropical because
that's where the greatest diversity is
but but not exclusively this trip the
trip here was a trip these this painting
in in part was a tribute to someone who
helped me identify a lot of small of the
micro orchids that just cover everything
when you're in a really nice dense
rainforest dr. Karl lure he's done 13
volumes in his lifetime and probably
another since I checked all on plural at
orchids most of which are epiphytic and
live in the upper reaches of trees
I just wanted to honor that it's such a
cool thing to do with your life one of
the reasons I had to email so much is
that a lot of birders have stopped
collecting
at all in the old days they would just
go shoot a whole suite of them and send
them all over the place they'd shoot
like a hundred birds and send them to
museums everywhere
well Dutch birders won't kill anything
anymore
they let everything go they take enough
samples and enough photographs and
measurements that they just say that's
all we need there's no reason to kill
them and keep them in dead drawers
somewhere they do take DNA samples of
course about this time I've been with a
wonderful gallerist in New York Hudson
at feature and Hudson died two days
before joining me at a big survey
exhibit I had so this is really tragic
for me but I made this but this makes me
happy so we had a memorial show for him
all the artists and the gallery made
things and this one was called oh this
one was called we were so lucky we were
lucky to have him as a friend and lucky
to work with him and I put it in because
I've made hundreds of these sort of
one-off pieces that I rarely show in my
talks and often I'll go to somebody's
house and I say where'd you where'd you
get that that looks really cool and they
say what you made it about 30 years ago
after working on this you know 10 is it
10 paintings over the course of about 14
years I promised myself I was going to
deal with ocean issues and it's really
hard it took me 6 months to come up with
an approach to even thinking about it
like how do you I don't want to do
Weiland you know how can I be
dispassionate about these creatures
because I I don't want to make nature
art that's you know Lions in the sunset
and all that kind of stuff I'm doing it
for a different reason I want it to last
and I also build it so that I can let
projects like this use the images to
have projects like this happen this is a
record that was made by you know now I
can't I don't have my glasses on so I
can't even see you is done by apologies
but it's recordings of animals that are
on the rise and animals that are on the
descent so I like using these images for
for political purposes
it's okay so back to oceans
they're huge how am I ever gonna parse
it you know all the other things I've
had like a logical pathway to get to the
subject matter and oceans are so big and
overwhelming and all the creatures have
all these body parts and I don't know
what they're for
so I decided that the rubric would be
they need to be everywhere they need to
be plentiful they need to be in all the
oceans and they need to be relatively
unknown by the general populace and oh
that's a good thing I can contribute
that so nudibranch s-- was the first one
I decided to do it I spent about know at
least a year learning about him before I
even start painting every nudibranch is
a hermaphrodite
they have both sets of equipment this is
to sort of standard new tube ranks
mating they will both go off and lay
eggs so they have both both sets and
they can they practice protandrous so
they don't have to be the same age
bracket they can be there can be a great
big one and a small one of the same
species and that's because they have a
really hard time finding each other
another side track of that is that
nudibranch penises are really weird
there's lots of Barb's and little cups
and things and every species is entirely
different and they're all kind of
designed so that ok we're together we're
not gonna let the tide blow us apart and
that's when I found out about penile
fencing so these are actually head
shield slugs they're still in the osteo
brank group very similar group H is the
head so we'll talk about the lower
animal because the other ones been
turned into a female the the penis goes
in like they do with all of them these
go side to side but where they fence is
with this second it's sort of like a
double a y-shaped thing the one on the
right the S thing is a like a hypodermic
needle and that's the part they fence
with they're each trying to stab the
other guy in the foot and the first guy
who stabs they inject a hormone which
makes the
who got injected first turn into a
female I mean the world is so much
stranger than I even give it credit for
and I see a lot of weird stuff this was
one of the little paintings I did that
was just so that I could familiarize
myself with new tube ranks and it's all
self defense that some of them bury in
the sand some slough off parts if they
get bitten
this bloke am a ferrous group can
actually flash a little bulb of luminous
a little bit and scare a predator
the group on there in the middle the
white one has glass spicules all over it
so any fish the bites that will just get
a mouthful of stickers the chrome adora
group has little pores all around the
mantle edge or they it's like they're
sort of a normal slug with a skirt over
it and all around the edge of the skirt
they have acid glands that can just send
off this noxious stuff but the coolest
ones are these ones with the pointy
sirata they mostly eat other things that
have stinging cells so sponges enemies
things like that and they don't digest
them they actually store the numata
cysts in the tips of their own Sarada
so they'll store them out here and
redeploy them but it only lasts for five
days so they have to keep eating them
but I just think that how do they know
not to digest this numata cyst it's
particularly since the digestive tract
is in these errata I know the world's
really they are all hermaphrodites every
one of them so on this picture you can
see so I put them in some different
positions you almost wouldn't even know
they're the same group of animals so
this is how they can look so spectacular
to come out a luscious animal you know
it's probably about this big so the
Rhino floors are these middle two pointy
bits Rhino means nose they smell their
world chemically that's how they
understand the world this is a chrome
adorn it with the skirt and man
and nudibranch actually means naked Gil
so these feathery parts on the group
that has the mantle are actually
breathing apparatus and as I was working
on him over the course of years I kept
calling that's the butt let it snow it's
Butlin but the mouth of this one is here
and the mouth of that one is kind of
below those little tentacles and they
can climb a bridge of slime they make
slime just like garden slugs so if they
if there's a slime trail that goes from
this rock to that plant that some other
went on other nudibranch went on or laid
down they can cross it too they can swim
on the underside of the water they can
swim like an eel some of them they're
really strange creatures they can if
they're some of them with particular
with this kind of sirata if they're
upset they can stick them all up in
bristle them like a pine porcupine so
and also some of them are just blood out
flat out cannibal they're cannibals and
I apologize I took these office sea slug
forum I didn't get very good photos but
this big blue thing oh yeah this is a
really good but unfortunately bill
Redmon's but retired so it I can't get
really good info off of it anymore
so this big blue thing is its mouth it's
sort of a averts this mouth and can
bring in food that way and the way they
pull it in or with these things it's
called a radula it's a little plate of
teeth like things that help them get a
grip on slimy new tube ranks and it's
how new tube ranks have always been
diagnosed speciated this little radula
depending on you know this big -
probably like that is excised out and
analyzed carefully with big like you
know scanning electron microscopes and
that dentition or rajala is how they've
always been speciated before DNA is
being used more and more but it's still
in its infancy plus nudibranch look like
basically like dried rubber some
once they're in formaldehyde so you kind
of have to I had to work from
photographs which wasn't bad these are
two typical new tube ranks they I keep
saying why are they these colors you
know they can't even see they really
can't it's well let's see I know where
it is
excuse me fer okay I know it's a bad
slide but you see there's a pink I mean
a yellow dot and the sort of rhino for
the ear like thing and behind that
yellow part this is a faint blue circle
that is their only light sensing organ
and it can basically tell them if
something is over them or not so they're
these crazy colors why and you know you
go 15 feet down there's you can't see
color anyway so I started looking at
that and here's a very recently
published article if you'd like to read
it about color in noted ranks but one of
the reasons is that they eat something
that they can you then redeploy the
pigment so this new tube rank eats his
rng pinky sponge and his eggs are that
color and he is that color because he's
actually redeployed the pigment others
this would be a completely clear new
tube rank except that he has resident
algae and they both share the food from
the production you know photosynthesis
of the algae called
zoos anthalie which is a fun word to say
this recent article says they think it
is really complex aposematic just you
know systems of avoidance but there are
lots and lots of memories there
tunicates that mimic ate them mimic
mimic them and there are flat worms that
mimic nudibranch so there's thousands of
these mimic greece so it's hard to tease
out why they're the color they are so
this is 206 of about 3,000 new tube
ranks we know of there's probably
another 3,000 I painted them as large as
they might ever grow just so I had a
little more room to play with them
and this is it looks like a black ground
over there when you look at it but
actually it's it's it's an optical black
it's actually a very very dark green
because the camera looks at that
differently this is the kind of thing
I've learned over really long time took
a long time to forget that out the top
road took me about a month to paint and
I used a straight pin to put most of it
on next what am I going to do next well
I want to work on shrimps and I don't
mean pink and on a plate they are really
diverse and it would be fun I've even
found one that has plaid two different
color eyeballs that our plaid I swear to
god they look plaid in the photos but I
also just got back from two weeks in
Suriname where I've been asked to do a
piece for a new US Embassy there on the
flora and fauna of Suriname so this
crimson headed mannequin will definitely
be in the picture because he's really
cute and then my new boyfriend Archie
I'm in love with but I want to do his
portrait fold by himself because he's
just such a glorious animal his tongue
is probably about this long he's a giant
anteater and they are lethal don't they
look benign and their mouth is really
three quarters of an inch wide and they
have no teeth it's a formidable amount
of ants to get to that size they hurt
people because they have about a 4 inch
3 inch and 2 inch dagger on this part
for cracking open termite nests that are
like cement and when they stand up
they're about this tall and if you piss
them off they'll take your head off and
it actually happened to someone who was
killing one to eat it and shot badly but
this guy was at a rescue center for
anteaters and sloths
I just can't wait to go back to Suriname
and I hope I get to go with the painting
thank you very much for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that was that was wonderful so
we're gonna get some questions so think
of your questions I'm gonna get a couple
to start off and cliff will have plenty
of time to chat afterwards one thing
that I'm not sure you touched on was
tell us more about your the way you
prepare these paintings to last for the
longtime selves so this is a survival of
of these species through your art tell
us a little bit more about how your
techniques for that well originally I I
painted on aged wooden panels with gesso
that I made from titanium dioxide and
rabbit skin glue and ground marble dust
they're very labor-intensive and you
just you just sit there for about a week
going like this it eventually gets
smooth but you don't want to do that on
something that's really big so I thought
I'm can't keep doing this as two takes
too much time so I started looking into
conservation ship on paintings and one
of the things that turned up was I read
about a material that's actually a very
fine French polyester that if they go to
Rebeck an old 300 year old painting this
is the material they use so I thought
there's got to be a reason they're using
it so I looked into the chemistry of it
and because it is polyester and because
I now use an Al Quaeda medium with only
Triple A rated sometimes double a but
there's still there materials that are
going to not change over the long course
of time the polymer chains that are
built around the molecules are the same
kinds of polymer chains that the fabric
is made of so there are two things that
cause deterioration in oil paintings one
is that there's they start stretching in
the middle so they stretch the middle
really tight and then they work out to
the edges and you'll see cracks that go
in a circle so there's different tension
on the fabric the other thing is that
anything
it's a natural fiber wicks moisture over
time so it goes in out in and out and it
makes cracks in that paint film that
wants to stick together because they
knew they were trying to make it last
but so I paint on polyester with
polyester and I actually got to sit next
to the chief conservator at the National
Gallery in London once and I said okay
you know everybody else was talking
about unfortunately were the only ones
interested in chemistry so I ran my
methods by him and he said you have as
good a shot as anybody else does so I
thought well but they'll you know and
what do you anticipate how long do you
anticipate they'll be able to last with
those techniques well they're much more
likely to get destroyed with flood fire
neglect one of the reasons I would never
have had the nerve to get my paintings
up into the price range they are but it
is a protection mechanism if you value
something it has a like greater
likelihood of surviving do we have any
question if you've got a question we've
got one right here and we've got a
microphone for you just a quick question
on the new drank baby the big ones down
below at the front are those life-size
and the little ones all the way back are
also life-size that's not perspective
we're seeing it's not perspective scale
scale and there they go much smaller
than four millimeters but I just decided
I didn't want to use a microscope to
paint with just say a little bit more
about that because you're painting
everything at it's real scale right has
that gotten absolutely ridiculous in
some situations a large species well I
usually will do something like use the
scat or some prints got it or a bone I
used the skull of a what is the
tasmanian tiger or thylacine thank you I
actually wrote someone who had
photographs of legitimate won't you know
actual specimens so I concluded it as
this call I got really interested in
seed longevity when I was working on
back because it's a resurrection idea
and I think you know Xander went as his
fall bard later I knew about Svalbard
before he went but I did find you know
examples of things that have been
dormant for on the order of eight
thousand years so there are seeds that
can last a really long time in the
tundra mostly permafrost and and just a
quick note on it earlier we're really
happy that we've got a lot of long now
members that are listening to our live
stream tonight so they're joining us
from afar long now members can listen in
to our talks thanks to Edward Burtynsky
a former speaker of ours who's given us
a grant to support that for this year so
we may have we'll see if we get any
questions if you're on the live stream
type them into the chat box and you'll
be able to ask your questions as well do
we have another question from the room
we've got I saw this oh we've got one
right here and then you'll be next
did you have the chance in your research
to actually interact with yes yes I I
originally got interested in them
because I my studio is a little
houseboat that I built and everybody
says don't you you know how do you move
but my easel and my chair and me all
moved the same way so it's not a problem
but I have caught eight different
species in the bay
right where I live and that's how I
first got interested in them because I
was I thought I'm gonna make a study of
the mud because it always looks
different and so one day I was looking
at the mud it's gonna leak there's all
these little teeny seaweeds and they
weren't seaweeds they were slugs laying
eggs and when I looked him up they look
like this white one this almost clear
one but they had they came in the bay
got the algae turned green laid eggs
left and went back to being clear so I
just thought that's really interesting
so that's how I got to do two banks in
the first place when you when you ask
your question just hold it up really
close you need to do that with these
bikes thank you
there you go what'swhat's your question
it's a very fuzzy question okay I'm
interested the kind of heightened
reality yes I mean obviously they're not
as you point out the species came from
all over the world and rest of them
right but in the way of the Dutch
masters that you described that's a
heightened sort of reality to this so
many questions I mean do you think what
a painter can do is much more
sophisticated than what a photograph can
do in that way there's interpretations
really working on something like this
does real life look bland you know
[Laughter]
because you know I like this part you
know I just was in a pretty intense
fairly pristine jungle for four days and
yeah a lot of it there's nothing there
but it all moves through if you just
wait I mean so yes my scenes are
incredibly imaginary and you know I
think nature movies make it seem like
you know oh here comes this and here
comes that and there's a lot of really
boring downtime in between but that's
when you look at spiders and you know
the kind of sand that's there and you
know there's always something to look at
that's interesting but no these are
completely sort of psychedelic I have
that advantage that you could be really
selective of what you're showing yeah
you can and whereas a photographer's
gotta wait for some behavioral thing
that is so rare to happen in front of
them I mean I meant I was didn't have
time but I was gonna say I always feel
guilty when I paint the brighter
prettier bird that's usually male you
know because it's adult the hens are
often kind of drab but you know what I'm
trying to do is get people excited and
engaged and if that's if I have to do it
this way this isn't such a bad price to
pay I make things at life-size and as
accurate as I can because I play a game
with myself I would like the person who
described the species the first time to
walk up and say that's my you know
buffalo so whatever it is I mean I'd
like the scientists themselves to be
able to recognize it
and it's a game this is just a mental
game but also it keeps me sharp so
what's actually written on that ostrich
egg oh it I can tell you exactly it says
found at near basada and it gives the
longitude and latitude and the date by
Colonel Colonel Dottie comma given to
Colonel Lawrence in 1846 I could go back
and check who later gave it to Richard
minor tog and you know who he was
he's do we have time to deliver a Z
story okay all right this owl was
thought to be extinct and Pamela
Rasmussen who works in that the
Smithsonian was putting together a new
book on the birds of Pakistan and India
and she thought you know that shouldn't
be right that should not be right that
bird should be somewhere else so she
looked at the egg this one Metheny bluey
died she got the specimens that were at
the British Museum and got the FBI
involved to analyze the ink what was
used to stuff them and it turns out that
Richard meinertzhagen who was a
flamboyant World War One SPY actually
wanted to have the biggest bird
collection in Britain private bird
collection in Britain and he went into
the British Museum and stole specimens
to complete his collection and he
rewrote the collection data Reiss tufted
and it turned out from some other
correspondence that she found that he
wasn't even in India when his collection
data was there so it was you know it was
this ridiculous theft
so Richard miner talking is one of the
people who had this egg so it could be
entirely suspect but so another quick
question about your techniques and so
tell us about the pigments that you use
and the tools you use are you I have a
paintbrush fetish but that's probably
knows
yeah like I figured out if you put a I
always save my undead ones you know the
bad brushes because I've started putting
a capo on it I saw people with a guitar
they put a cape on so I built like
paperclip Capo's that spread the brushes
out like that and then I can make bird
bird prints really easily like feather
prints really easily so as I say I have
a sculptors approach to making paintings
they're more you know conceptual pieces
to me then yeah it's a lot of execution
and technique but to me they're more
conceptual because I'm building them for
a very particular purpose and I want
them to be used a certain way and you
know I have an intent behind them so
with the to know but I didn't talk about
the well you know there's now a rating
agency that rates pigments of course
they probably only do tests it lasts for
about six minutes or six years not very
long and also you know when it says safe
non-toxic to humans on a on an art
material it means that less than half of
the rats died so be careful and I was
gonna ask you for what's a tiny detail
with the two paintings that we have here
is there one tiny detail that you can
kind of only appreciate in person is
there some little little detail you can
point us towards as we have this brief
moment together so closely I always have
ants and people like yo Wilson always
finds them
I might sometimes have as many as 15
species in there I mean you can't
speciate them at that level you know but
but they are in there as placeholders
for themselves what I what I want to do
is make these plants and animals speak
for themselves and and tell their story
without objectifying it or humanizing it
too much just it's I'm not talking about
me I'm talking about them see if I've
got one more maybe further do we have
Mike out the front the back was consumed
from the back have you thought of trying
to imagine future life-forms yeah I've
been leaving that to Alexis Rahman he's
doing a good job with that
um no but what I have entertained a lot
and I bought um I was given a microscope
so that I might do it is sometime
address the smaller than eyesight world
and I'd like to do that but there's a
very big problem with that there's the
only color is reflection so how do I
paint that and also we it's easy for us
to think you know 1 X 10 X 20 X hundred
X that's not so easy to do in a painting
that involves scale so I haven't
resolved it you know uh I think it was
Bill who's I was talking to a really
smart person who's paid a lot of
attention to natural things in
California really noses birds and and I
said so what about the grasses and he
said and he was probably 80 at the time
he said I'm saving that for when I'm
really old so I might be saving that to
him really old there's so much to work
on I mean there's endless possibilities
of things that would be you know I'm
trying to capture our attitudes in these
paintings it's like trying to make a
time capsule of how we are thinking
about our relationship to the natural
world with them so I have a lot of
material so we're gonna wrap up the
stage portion and hopefully everyone's
gonna stay around you'll stick around
tell some more more stories expand on
some that you touched on here lastly
you've got some books that are here do
you want to just tell us briefly what
what those are yeah I have a few books
called taxa that are the six paintings
in the taxes series starting with
descendant they were produced by my
gallerist in New York and if you would
like to buy one I'm donating the
proceeds to revive and restore tonight
so
thank you and those will be at the back
and of course you won't be well thank
you so much for for being a great
audience thank you for a wonderful thank
you thanks go back soon
[Music]